dort wird ihnen präsentiert von 107
[Musik]
es gibt die wildnis auch in der
zivilisation wenigstens stückweise
[Applaus]
die schweiz ist ein überhitztes land
tausende von pflanzen und tierarten sind
vom aussterben bedroht
doch da ist auch eine andere schweiz
dort wächst der wald zu neuer wildnis
tiere die längst ausgerottet waren
kehren zurück etwa der bär zum ersten
mal wieder in den kanton uri der bart
kaya der größte vogel europas segelt
erneut in den alpen und den war traten
wird das fliegen wieder beigebracht
reno sommerhalder der schweizerisch
kanadische bären forscher sucht weltweit
orte auf wo die wildnis zurückkehrt
im kongo gott darum dass wir uns einfach
wieder ein schritt nach hört der natur
und nöten schritt wieder zurücktreten
wie man das letzte hund und jahr
vielleicht macht hans und womöglich wird
auch das größte sorge tier europas in
der schweiz wieder heimisch werden
jahrhunderte nach seinem verschwinden
[Musik]
vor 30 jahren ist reno sommerhalder
gebürtiger schweizer nach banff gezogen
in den ältesten nationalpark kanadas
hier wirkt er als sperren experte als
vortragsreisender als weltweit tätiger
missionar für eine intakte natur
band bietet eine betörende schert tier
und pflanzenwelt auf eine fläche die
größer ist als der kanton bern
eigentlich ist das eine perfekte wildnis
[Musik]
doch etwas fehlt der bison vor 130
jahren wurde er hier ausgerottet
division hat sich über 100 die musik für
jahre entwickelt und der nische der
nationalpark der hat eine steppe
regionen post
der wiso curto der trainer gehört und
dann aber so nicht mehr vorhanden um
mehr in front die größe fahrer vor der
vergangenheit richtig zu machen
ein halbes jahr später es ist januar
2017 normal dass wunsch geht in
erfüllung
die kanadische regierung bringt in
gießen zurück nach banff 16 tiere aus
dem nationalpark l thailand soll und ein
anfang machen für eine neue population
400 kilometer weit geht die reise durch
die provinz alberta in bands sollen die
bisons die ökologie bereichern als
grasfresser die flächen offen halten als
beutetiere den wölfen bären und pumas
das überleben nun erleichtern
die letzten 25 kilometer hinein ins
abgelegene sind nur noch mit einem
helikopter zu bewältigen
[Musik]
anderthalb jahre werden die bisons in
einem großen gehege gehalten und
beobachtet
danach sollen sie völlig ausgewildert
werden
10 trächtige weibchen sechs junge
brunnen
ein halbes jahr später wird diese herde
bereits um zehn frisch geborene kälber
gewachsen sein
welchen ruhe im solothurner jura der ruf
soll matt hier sollen erstmals in der
schweiz wie center wieder heimisch
werden
diese europäischen verwandten der bisons
benjamin grund könnte der erste wisent
rangers schwarz werden die idee zu
diesem vorhaben stammt von
naturschützern und biologen und der
biobauer die sich dafür begeistern
performance also immer gut vorstellbar
der naturpark thal erstreckt sich über
große waldgebiete 10 wisente sollen in
einem 100 hektar gehege zuerst
beobachtet und dann nach zwei jahren in
freiheit entlassen werden
die waldbesitzerin die bürgergemeinde
solothurn hat bereits ihr einverständnis
gegeben
brunners nachbarn allerdings haben
bedenken
sie fürchten die wisente als mögliche
mutter rolle
was antwortet ihnen benjamin brinner
sagen wir es halt da und warte wo die
rugby schade seine kamera und kauter und
da der mit seiner frau ist und mir
versprochen an sich funktioniert 1000
rappaz brunner betreibt heute mutter
tierhaltung damit das publikum auch
wirklich wisente zu gesicht bekommt
plant der eigens ein schaugehege
einzurichten
das kemptener prem dorer shantychor
vorteile messungen aber und gehen total
waldecker zwei kreisläufern das land
froese naturpark thal risiko für
gastronomiebetriebe war ich mir das
eigentlich gesamtschweizerisch ist und
total kann das natürlich chance gab
der sanfte tourismus wisente in der
schweiz
es gibt sie schon allerdings nur hinter
zäunen mehrere schweizer zu ross
präsentieren diese archaischen kolosse
der tierpark goldau züchtet sie seit
tierpfleger bruno ärger ist mit den
europäischen bisons vertraut sind
unglaublich hören dürfen sich alle mit
alles erlogen einfach dass mika direkte
kontakt will ja schwierig doch wirkst du
sie kilo mehr als vom vorstand habe ich
das problem müssen vorsichtig mit strom
dass ich nie passiert wird man muss man
nichrt ränder dass man zusammen mit mehr
problemen kam mit einer näheren umfeld
das eine havarie sei aber sonst sind
sich ziemlich einfach hätte er zum haben
zum händler frühesten schaffen
der tierpark goldau beteiligt sich aktiv
an der wiederansiedlung der wisente in
europa bereits sieben vicente aus der
innerschweiz sind in osteuropäische
welter gegangen
reno sommerhalder trifft tierarzt martin
wehrle von der tierpark direktion
dieser ist mit dem
wiederansiedlungsprojekt befasst wie
beurteilt er die idee vicente auch im
jura auszuwildern projekt eine große
waldgebiet wie sie inhalte natürlichen
bedingungen wie gelabert also ich denke
es könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen
mit der entwicklung von der
landwirtschaft richtig extensiv zum teil
zehn jahren natürlich auch verschiedene
betrieb wo die intensive landwirtschaft
auf die hand und aus wieder für natur
für natürlich die raute wiederansiedlung
von tirol platz gehen
ein frühlingsmorgen oberhalb des
bodensees im deutschen überlingen eine
kleine wohnwagensiedlung etwas außerhalb
des ortes in der nähe hat reno
sommerhalder sein zelt aufgeschlagen
das camp der waldrapp ein ibis vogel der
vor 400 jahren in europa ausgerottet
worden ist zu lecker schmeckte den
menschen damals das fleisch dieses
tieres
nun bemühen sich menschen von heute den
vogel in europa weder in die luft zu
bringen
ein eigenartiges bild zwei junge frauen
sitzen fast tage lang im gehege und
herzen die jungen watt ab
das heißt dass ich eigentlich den ganzen
tag für die vier jahren also sie haben
mit meiner kollegin durchwinken
streicheln sie bezeichnen was nichts
gefährliches wir zeigen ihnen was
gefährliches also lernen von uns wenn
man sie bringen eigentlich den ganzen
tag mit würde so lange bis man sie dann
in die freiheit entlassen können sich
uns sehr neugierig zu müssen alle
schlitten schnabel betasten was ich
finden alles neu sie sind sehr
anhänglich einheiten ein erfolg oder
misserfolg dieses projektes hängen davon
ab ob die für juli frauen als ziemlicher
akzeptieren
die 31 jungen zugvögel stammen aus zoos
und haben keine ahnung von flugrouten
keine vogelmutter konnte es ihnen zeigen
deshalb sollen sie ende sommer den
beiden zehn metern ins winterquartier in
die toskana folgen verstehen das
interesse und den waldrappen nicht groß
immer wieder lassen sich besucher über
das projekt ins bild setzen
da ist viel sympathie für den speziellen
vogel hängt sicher damit zusammen auch
das eigentlich kein konfliktpotenzial
hat dass das ist natürlich immer großes
thema aber wir ansiedlungen und da sind
wir recht gut bedient sorgen in waltrop
er machte weder im ökosystem einen
schaden verdrängt keine anderen daten
aber insbesondere auch es ist konflikt
mit den frischen interessensgruppen
dauer landwirtschaft forst jagd
fischerei in vier jahren hat das
waldrapp team 70 vögel auf die richtige
flugroute gebracht
ein erfolg der allerdings bedroht ist
durch die skis lust in italien 5
waldrappe wurden dort im letzten herbst
vom himmel geschossen
mehrheitlich die italienischen vogel je
gehalten sich schon an die richtlinien
also schießen auf das was an vogelarten
legitimes zu schießen jetzt noch nach
jagdrecht gewisser prozentsatz schert
sich darum offensichtlich nichts ist der
fall es eben auch waldrappe wir haben
wenig also die erfahrungen diebe haben
zeigen dass sie nicht bewusst gezielt
darf waldrappe schießen sondern dass sie
einfach auf alles schießen wenn das
walter bist dann ist immer valtra ca in
der schweiz berühmt wurde der einsame
shorty ein wahlgrab weibchen dass sich
2014 und 15 aus der toskana in die
schweiz verirrte der zweite schweiz
besucht den fugen fast das leben
gekostet
immer überlebt wenn nicht ein fußgänger
der hat den am boden gefunden im winter
schon an gefrorenen flüge hab ich ihn im
gepäck golda dänischer aufgenommen
worden und betreut worden und hat es
überstanden aber seitdem lassen wir den
vogel immer migrieren also der lebt zwar
mit unseren waldrappen mit aber wir
transportieren ihn im herbst immer ins
wintergebiet und transferieren im
frühjahr wieder ins brutgebiet
du kannst die vögel zwischen 42 und 54
tage alt sind inzwischen alle flüge
schon in einigen tagen wird man mit dem
spektakulären flug training beginnen
können
[Musik]
im äußersten osten von polen an der
grenze zu weißrussland
hier liegt der nationalpark von bioware
in seinem kerngebiet der größte urwald
europas
fast magisch wirkt die wildnis von
bialowieza es ist frühling
der feuchte boden ist übersät von
buschwindröschen erinnern halter ist auf
der suche nach dem größten wild lebenden
säugetiere europas
es muss in der nähe seien frische wiesen
spuren sind überall zu sehen
eigentlich ist es ein waldtier doch
gelegentlich so der grasfresser nach
nahrung auch in den umliegenden wiesen
heute jedoch bleibt das tier unsichtbar
eines hat somerhalder an diesem tag
gelernt
es braucht glück um wisente in freier
wildbahn beobachten zu können
die polnische akademie der wissenschaft
in bialowieza fall kowalczyk ist einer
der renommiertesten wiesen forscher
schränke voller schädel verdeutlichen
den umfang seiner forschung
[Musik]
es ist ein einzigartiges tier alle heute
frei lebenden wisente stammen von
einigen zu tieren ab die überlebt haben
heute gibt es in europa wieder an
mehreren orten wilde wie sind doch noch
immer ist diese spezies seltener als
beispielsweise das schwarze nashorn
welches ein symbol ist für die bedrohten
tierarten
deshalb ist der wert des wisent
vergleichbar mit jenem des schwarzen
nashorns der wisent ist könnte man sagen
dass schwarze nase europa hätten sie
eine empfehlung für die schweiz wo man
ebenfalls wieder wisente ausliefern
möchte jede wiederansiedlung ist zu
begrüßen doch dazu braucht es einen
passenden lebensraum ein waldgebiet
gemischt mit offenem gelände
gemäß unserer forschung lebt in vicente
vor rund 2.000 3.000 jahren im gebiet
der schweiz
damit würde also dieses große tier
zurückkehren
das ist eine großartige idee es würde
überdies die touristische attraktivität
der region erhielten
es würde also der wirtschaft dort einen
schub verleihen
fahrt vor sonnenaufgang aus dem dorf ins
nahe umland auf der suche nach wegen wie
senden
vor neunzig jahren waren d'isere
gänzlich ausgerottet
1952 wurden erstmals sowie center in die
liga wieder ausgewildert heute leben
erneut 1000 dieser tiere im polnisch
weißrussischen wald die chancen dieser
außerhalb des waldes zu sehen sind in
den morgenstunden am besten haben sich
die tiere erstmal ins gehölz
zurückgezogen ist es schwierig wisente
aufzuspüren
möglicherweise erhalten sich welche dort
auf den feldern auf es ist ein gebiet
außerhalb des nationalparks wo grasland
futter verspricht in einer wald glück
liegen zwei bullen
nachdem sie die menschen entdeckt haben
werden sie unruhig
[Musik]
sind wir sind die gefährlich für
menschen
wenn man die tiere nicht stört und eine
gewisse distanz ein held sind sie
unproblematisch
es gab kaum attacken auf touristen
das problem ist dass die leute
aufzunehmen
sie stören die tiere besonders wenn sie
sich mit ihren handys für fotos nähe
dann kann es vorkommen dass die wisente
die leute davon jagen doch meist stoppen
die tiere dann ein eigentlicher angriff
kommt sehr selten vor
bis heute gab es bei solchen vorfällen
noch nie tut der wald von biologischer
ist in seinem kern eine der letzten
großen urwälder europas der größte
und dieser lebensraum der wisente ist
bedroht die polnische regierung hat
große flächen zum abholzen freigegeben
weltweit wurden proteste dagegen laut
sowohl die unesco als auch der
europäische gerichtshof haben die
regierung aufgefordert die zerstörung
des waldes einzustellen
bislang vergeblich das ist ein
einzigartiger wald er ist seit der
letzten eiszeit in 12.000 jahren
kontinuierlich gewachsen
das ist der bestbewachte wald in europa
wir brauchen solche gebiete
er ist auch wichtig aus touristischer
sicht touristen kommen nicht hierher um
einen gewöhnlichen bewirtschafteten wald
zu besuchen
die menschen wollen diesen einzigartigen
vielfältigen wald sehen der auch magisch
ist dunkel feucht das polnische dorf
welches dem urwald den namen gab in den
letzten jahren hat der kleine grenzort
einen wirtschaftlichen aufschwung
erfahren
dank der touristischen anziehungskraft
des nationalparks wisente sind zum
wirtschaftlichen glücksbringer der
menschen hier geworden aus ganz europa
kommen besucher um nach den großen
tieren zu suchen in einem wald der nun
durch eine kurzsichtige holzwirtschaft
womöglich unwiederbringlich schaden
erleidet
reno sommerhalder geht noch einmal in
die wildnis in diesem wald der so riesig
ist das 1000 mächtige tiere darin
unsichtbar verschwinden können
[Musik]
und dann unvermittelt zeigt sich
zwischen den bäumen ein wie seine pole
wenige meter entfernt ein zweites tier
[Musik]
archaische kraft strotzende lebewesen
die in die urzeit zurückweisen und sich
im europa der gegenwart allmählich
wieder etwas raum erobern
[Musik]
das bonner isenthal abgelegen und reich
vor rund 200 jahren war hier einer der
letzten urner bären zu gange ein
einzelgänger der die leute damals in
angst und schrecken versetzt eine
treibjagd brachte hier den bären zur
strecke
geschossen am 29 mai 1820 seither
präsentiert das dorf die bärentatzen der
öffentlichkeit
diese sollten wohl den triumph über das
scheinbar böse bedeuten
doch aus der trophäe ist inzwischen ein
symbol geworden für eine gewandelte
beziehung mensch natur so schreibt der
örtliche tourismusverein und lädt auf
einen bären weg ein
und nun 200 jahre später ist erstmals
wieder ein bär ins urnerland
zurückgekehrt unterwegs war er vor allem
im schächental dem arbeitsgebiet von
wildhüter fredy arnold im sommer 2016
ist daher angekommen
ein halbes jahr später ende winter ist
ungewiss wo das tier geblieben ist
die liegenschaft ich da in dem lager
holger richter er war ich dann reden so
dura und ich mache richtig zugriff von
vorrätig noch fertig sind dass ich am 28
oktober zu weiten und sagte einmal kann
sich auch mit und so ist das urner
schächental ein stark besiedeltes
bergtal zum boomland geworden ist der
bär noch hier
[Musik]
unten im reusstal kündigt sich der
frühling gemessen sind aus den hüllen
herunter gestiegen um zwischen den
schneeresten etwas gras zu finden
es ist ende winter wenn der bär noch nie
ist wird er in nächster zeit wieder
auftauchen müssen sich reisende ja immer
und ob dass ich wieder grip verhalten
wird es schon schwierig zu sagen
das letzte das ich sehr gehört verhoben
der kein problem kaputter stars ja
wieder ich ja weiß neben rot sofa war
zwar schön war der badeort warf ließ
sich erlauben
am horizont der suren pass wo kürzlich
eine andere weniger schöne geschichte
ihr ende fand fredy arnold und seine
kollegen mussten dort einen wall
verlegen der auf den urner schafweiden
gewütet hatte fredy arnold hat die ganze
deren geschichte dokumentiert die im
juni so begonnen hat am morgen hatte der
hai als lustig sie erregen kann ja der
bürger und daher ein bisschen traurig
sagt ja aber sie schließen und der
rückseite siegte bieber viel wie es hat
ja auch was holzschnitten der karotte
und dann schießen sieht sicher ewigen
date bisher wirklich notwendig bogenball
oder pdfs sie erkannt oder bühl mehr das
gemeldet
es war vermutlich dieser bär der zuvor
im bündnerland in eine fotofalle geraten
war
groß ist dieser maxi oder schoko aber im
verlauf vom summen wird sich sehr sehr
unfair verhalten hat der islam aus dass
ich alles nicht passiert oder so ich
noch topfit als wenn ich ein einfacher
oberlage riskieren es gab viele spuren
aber nur wenige menschen konnten den
jungen bären auch sehen dass ich für
mich also ein wagnis somerhalder
unterwegs im trentino
von hier stammen der ohner wehr wie auch
das übrige dutzend bären welches seit
2005 die schweiz besucht hat
der naturpark adamello brenta in der
italienischen provinz trentino
es ist der lebensraum der europäischen
alpen braunbären
nur 40 kilometer sind es von hier ins
schweizerische roche love es ist mai und
reno sommerhalder hat sich aufgemacht zu
einer ersten erkundung der gegend
obschon die zivilisation richten scheint
sind bereits weniger hundert höhenmeter
weiter oben keine menschen mehr
anzutreffen zu steil zu wild ist dieses
italienische alpenland sommerhalter
sucht nach stellen wo sich wildtier
kameras erfolgversprechend montieren
lassen
sie stellt aber eigentlich ideal
zwischenablage abgeknickt opel mit viel
grün zügig fröhlich die erste große
brocken ist im nacken wald vom letzten
jahres bei wenig manager thomas ist kann
wann der magischen wildkatzen
wildwechsel möglichkeit das image
leichter
[Musik]
ein mehrstündiger aufstieg führt über
die waldgrenze hinaus
zelt filmausrüstung und die verpflegung
für mehrere tage lasten auf dem rücken
reno sommerhalder hofft hiermit bären in
kontakt zu kommen
und dann tatsächlich ein männchen bewegt
sich in steilen
auf der krete erscheint ein zweites tier
ein weibchen
offenbar wird reno sommerhalder hier
zeuge eine liebesgeschichte
[Musik]
er beschließt an dieser stelle aus zu
haben denn die lage gestattet einen
weiten blick über das tal eine halbe
stunde später eine hirschkuh scheint vor
dem menschen zu fliehen doch schnell
wird klar das tier nahm reißaus vor dem
bären pärchen von vorhin welches
mittlerweile das tal in unglaublich
schnell umgang durchquert hat die tiere
scheinen liebesblind beachten den
menschen nicht
wenig später taucht ein zweites münchen
auf der eigenartige breitbeinige gang
sommerhalter nennt es einen cowboy
shuffle verrät dass paarungsbereiten
männchen das eindruck machen möchte
doch die mühen dieses münchens sind
vergebens das weibchen hat sich bereits
für den anderen entschieden
der wert liegt das mittels doch die
beobachter
die hätte hätte ich niemals co es ist
sicher so wirklich ganz ganz
beschönigung fantastische und extrem
unerwartet die beobachtung ist dass
google nicht das ist für mich wahnsinnig
der herzschlag spüren
aigner war sehr viel schneller schlapp
aber der herzog vor der natur der
herzschlag vor dem ökosystem und bei der
symbolisiert ein intaktes ökosystem und
das ist also nicht ständig schumacher
reno sommerhalder steigt weiter auf der
schnee der hier oben in den letzten
tagen noch mal gefallen ist rückt näher
[Musik]
eine herde mufflons bild schafe
eigentlich gehören diese tiere nicht
hierher
sie sind von jägern ausgesetzt worden um
etwas vor die flinte zu kriegen
[Musik]
reno sommerhalder beschließt sein zelt
auf einem berg grad zu errichten
[Musik]
und nochmal lässt sich ein bär blicken
ganz in der nähe des zeltes
es ist das helle weibchen vom nachmittag
[Musik]
trient die hauptstadt der provinz
trentino im verwaltungsgebäude der
provinzregierung ist auch dass
umweltschutz der parlament untergebracht
hier wirkt claudio prof er hat die
wiederansiedlung der bären im trentino
in den letzten 20 jahren geleitet
in jüngster zeit ist seine arbeit
schwieriger geworden unsere
untersuchungen zeigen dass die akzeptanz
heute viel schlechter ist als zu beginn
des projekts das hatte auch damit zu tun
dass wir heute viel mehr bären haben von
2002 bis 2015 ist die population auf
rund 50 bären gewachsen
es gibt also auch mehr schäden und da
waren zudem einige sehr nahe begegnungen
und sogar unfälle
ein mann wurde dabei ernsthaft verletzt
dies hat die zustimmung schlechter
werden lassen
überdies haben wir auch festgestellt
dass die wilderei zunimmt
wir fanden vergiftete bären und einer
wurde erschossen
und das sind nur jene die wir gefunden
haben und nun ist ein bär aus dem
trentino auch erstmals ins innerste der
schweiz in den kanton uri gewandert wenn
wir diesen tieren wirklich eine chance
geben wollen in den alpen zu leben
dann müssen wir etwas toleranter sein
als bisher
das heißt wir müssen auch bereit sein
schäden zu akzeptieren gewiss schäden
können zu einem großen teil verhindert
werden wenn man es richtig macht doch
ganz verhindern kann man sie nicht wenn
man 0 schäden will dann hat man 0 bären
0 50 lux
doch wir möchten keine alpen ohne diese
tiere also müssen wir toleranter werden
und ernsthaft an der prävention von
schäden arbeiten und hier in ist die
schweiz gut wie mir scheint
der mensch ist
das trentino bärenland es ist auch ein
tourismusland
in madonna di campiglio muss man gar von
einer tourismusindustrie sprechen in
diesen trüben tagen steht die maschine
still
doch in der hochsaison fühlen sich
50.000 betten drei millionen
übernachtungen zählt die region jährlich
was bedeutet es in diesem hoch
gerüsteten touristenzentrum geben bären
zu lieben
ich glaube bären sind eine chance für
unsere destination weil die menschen
fasziniert sind von ihnen andererseits
fürchten sich menschen manchmal auch vor
bären
denn offensichtlich sind es starke
mächtige tiere wären sind überall
präsent in madonna di campiglio
die pelztiere sind dienlich die
sehnsucht der städtischen menschen nach
natur nach wildnis anzuregen
deren freien unserem touristischen image
auftrieb denn bären in dieser gegend
leben bedeutet dies dass die qualität
der natur sehr hoch ist der bär ist ein
qualitätsmerkmal tourismusmanager matteo
von apache lebt seit jeher in diesem tal
doch selbst hatte in seinem leben erst
einmal einen bären gesehen
die bären sind zurückhaltende mit
bewohner dieses landes
morgendliche ford in eines der vielen
wilden täler claudio griff der chef des
trentino bären projekt ist unterwegs zu
einem ort wo in den letzten tagen
mehrere bären gesichtet worden sind
[Musik]
in dieser menschenleeren tal treffen
sich im frühling bären jeweils zu caro
fast unglaublich in diesem steilen fels
abhang sollen bären leben sind zwei wie
bree und dass man sie wahnsinnig steigen
aber das hat also vorsprung sogar aus
vorsprung und die da oben sind die
beobachtet wurde und das ist eigentlich
typisch für hollywood üblich wäre der
bauxite jetzt stattfindet hofer gibt dem
kunden das free sich dann die alpine
grund mussten befriedigt an und sie
besseren kontrollieren offenland claudio
graf ist unterwegs mit mitarbeitern und
einem journalisten der re publica einer
einflussreichen italienischen zeitung
kommunikation ist eine wichtige
tätigkeit grafs verständnis wecken in
zeiten schwindender akzeptanz in der
nacht zuvor viel starker regen die luft
ist mit feuchtigkeit gesättigt
die gruppe steigt höher hinauf in der
hoffnung der nebel möge sich etwas
lichten ein kratzbaum an einem nagel
hängt ein bild bären harnstoff dass das
die hauses besser hängen blieben und die
dünnsten nissan und genetik loslassen
[Musik]
gelegentlich öffnet sich die sicht kurz
auf die felsige bergflanke an der
gegenüberliegenden talseite wo sich
bären aufhalten sollen
dann schiebt sich wieder eine nebelwand
vor den ausblick das liebesspiel der
bären bleibt heute vor menschlichen
blicken geschützt
man beschließt den aufstieg wenigstens
für das anbringen einer wildtier kamera
zu nutzen
frühere resultate einer fotofalle zeigen
so eindrücklich kann das bären vorkommen
im trentino aussehen
[Musik]
das ist eine gegend oder wer stets
präsent ist
weißt du willst es sind mehrere wehren
wenn man das hier richtig macht und die
batterie in schuss hält ist es zu 99
prozent sicher
die provinzregierung entschädigt für
schäden durch bären und bezahlt auch für
maßnahmen zur verhinderung von solchen
wie diese absicherung eines
bienenhäuschen und doch schäden wird es
trotzdem geben
und am schlimmsten ist wenn menschen
betroffen sind
gleich vier solcher unfälle haben sich
in den letzten drei jahren ereignet
ja das war sehr hart
diese situationen zu handhaben für mich
alle die sich mit den bären befassen
da besteht kein zweifel die
anstrengungen zur prävention wurden noch
mal verstärkt noch mehr aufklärung noch
mehr orientierungsversammlung gewiss das
kann wieder passieren das ist klar
wir können nicht 100 prozent sicher sein
überall auf der welt was bären gibt
können solche unfälle vorkommen doch
wenn man weiß wie sich verhalten kann
man dieses risiko sehr sehr stark
vermindert das risiko muss auch gering
sein
andernfalls kann man es den menschen die
hier leben nicht zumute
ja
in deutschen allgäu 40 km vom bodensee
entfernt
600 jahre lang lebten hier st galler
menschen heute wohnt hier ein mann
dessen spiritualität der natur und ihrem
kosmos gilt wolf dieter storl ein
deutsch-amerikanischer
kulturanthropologe autor zahlreicher
bücher über pflanzen und ihre kräfte
wildnis ist die natur wie sie in sich
ist ohne ohne unsere technologie und
einwirkung es ist was die chinesen zum
beispiel als zuschauer
bezeichnend und das finde ich so
wunderbar während ich hier sitze wächst
das gras von ganz allein und die wolken
schweben da braucht man nichts zu machen
und dieses ist in einer harmonie
denn wenn man in die natur schaut
besonders in urwälder oder natürlich
[Musik]
gegenden immer harmonisch mia findet man
dass die blumen passen nicht zusammen
deswegen tut es uns gut denn es erzeugt
in uns resonanz so dass wir auch etwas
von dieser natürlichen harmonie
mitbekommen und das können wir in den
alltag hineintragen
und woher rührt die angst der menschen
vor dieser wildnis
wir waren jäger und sammler als menschen
mindestens drei millionen jahre lang und
erst die zivilisierten menschen
entwickelten eine angst für die
naturvölker die ich als ethnologe kenne
ist die natur das zuhause da fühlt man
sich gut in der heutigen zeit haben die
menschen angst weil sie so weit
entfremdet sind die entfremdung von der
natur ist zugleich eine fremde von ihrem
wahren selbst und entfremdete menschen
lassen sich auch besser beherrschen und
ich sehe keinen grund angst vor der
natur zu haben ich habe eher angst vor
der stadt
wer angst vor den menschen als wie vor
der natur
wolf dieter storl der wildnis philosoph
ist auch ein kenner des schweren lebens
der löwenzahn ist eine der wichtigsten
pflanzen für die crystal und
schwarzbären kanada bei uns im frühling
jetzt im juni festen sich wie waren sie
meint aber was hat er ihnen das so
wichtig ist für die bayern wichtig sein
also denkt voller vitamine und
mineralien
es hat auch für kali was dennoch den
stoffwechsel reinigt und die bären die
fressen
die fressen ja als allererstes wenn sie
rauskommen empfohlen weißenseer sachen
die erstmal den stuhlgang in gang setzen
ja es heißt ja bei den indianern dass
die ja sogar hin scheinen und in
albanien überhaupt dass die bären die
meister der pflanzenkunde sind die
wissen instinktiv mit diesen wunderbaren
riecht vermögen
die können ja kennt das sprichwort ein
adler sieht ein blatt fallen 1
was ein kojote hört s und r b richters
warum glaubst du brauchen wir menschen
die natur
wir haben immer mit und in der natur
gelebt und das die natur ist unser
zuhause wir sind angepasst an die natur
und wir werden krank in der heutigen
zeit durch natur ferne
und das wird wie umgekehrt als ob die
natur uns krank macht das gibt es leute
die haben angst vor fuchsbandwurm und
jetzt der hantavirus das schon mal
gehört
also mein gott dann lebt man lieber in
kleinen kasten kriegt die natur virtuell
mit und dann mit aromatherapie noch
einige natur dürfte
und dann ist man sicher ihr solange sie
so glänzend ist ein wissenschaftler der
sein wissen auch jenseits der
wissenschaft ich bin immer noch
wissenschaftler aber bin über die
grenzen hinaus
und weil ich immer wieder gespürt habe
und da denke ich so auch den
naturvölkern die ich kannte und der
eigenen intuition die die welt hört
nicht auf wo die empirische wissenschaft
ihre grenzen hat sondern uns unsere welt
unser universum ist viel viel tiefer und
ist eigentlich unendlich tief ja
die wildnis die wilde natur hat uns
uhrzeiten begleitet sie ist eigentlich
das zuhause unserer seele
ja ich habe das hier vergnügen die boote
nicht gelungen
der inhaber ist erwacht aus dem
winterschlaf
zuhinterst im schächental oben am
klausenpass auf 1900 meter höher
wildhüter fredy arnold zeigt reno
sommerhalder wo er kürzlich die ersten
spuren des bären im schnee entdeckt hat
der urner per der irgendwo da draußen so
unauffällig durch die gegend streift ist
ein junges männchen und soweit bekannt
waren dies auch die anderen bären welche
seit 2005 in die schweiz kamen
spätestens mit der geschlechtsreife
zieht es die bären jünglinge jedoch
wieder zurück ins trentino
denn hierzulande finden sie keine liebe
in dir sehen außer der ps vita und der
junge mann gibt sich sehr intensiv zieht
sie ist sehr intensiv die absicht euro
um 100 wenig wie ist denn das saufen
frau gesehen telefons evo angst dass ich
bete dass er sich so verhalte sich ist
aber erwies sich nicht als ich ja nicht
passiert beseitigt diese sollen das hat
man einmal nicht für solid agassa mentos
der sohn des großen downloads findet man
sich dann ist das ein wenig für die
ganze regierung
dazu kommt das gefühl das ist sehr
positiv oder stimmt's elegant wie jenes
das stimmt das und das haben sie aber
gar den ruf dass ich wenige besonders
dass sich das verstehe ich also durch
einfach druck substanz nicht
fredy arnold war früher auch jäger er
ist ein mann des tschechen teils seine
nachbarn sind bauern als wildhüter hat
er da oft eine schwierige arbeit vor uns
die aula in bürglen ist voll besetzt als
die ordner behörden die bevölkerung über
den bären informieren detailliert
schildern wildhüter fredy arnold und
seine kollegen den besuch des großraums
im innerschweizer kanton jede sichtung
wird erwähnt jede spur erläutert es soll
niemand sagen können dinge seien unter
den teppich gekehrt worden
josef falke der urner jagdverwalter
erzählt vom abschuss des letzten bären
im urnerland und er schildert das
heutige schweizer bären konzept in
welchem es den unauffälligen bären gibt
den problembären und für das tier eine
tödliche kategorie den risiko bären
josef volk streut den menschen keinen
sand in die augen
barbara becker ex-frau jungbären im
spiel sind mit kabel 1 hat den schock
war in 7 42 jährigen bargeld und das ist
dann natürlich das ganze sache
das publikum verdankt die transparenz
mit applaus da ist nicht eine einzige
kritische frage ist doch ein kunde eine
wertvolle um es noch einmal gesagt wer
wenig beobachtet vorliegt oder
refraktären und die welle die stadt
jetzt doch nicht das letzte sein
es gibt in uri aber auch eine opposition
gegen die grossraubtiere eine gruppe von
jägern und bauern hat eine kantonale
initiative lanciert unter anderem sollen
wolf und bär im schadensfall schneller
getötet werden können
christian arnold bauer und svp landrat
ist einer der initianten sind davis in
tokio ist in hautnah bugsierte das
inland roma kranker für den praktiker
chancen zweiter und christsein
eigentlich haben wir bisher nicht
geschafft respektiv nehme man gesichter
sind einfach ja auch ich muss richtiger
verstolpert ich hoffe dann sind
bestätigen gleich aus dem grund ist
doppelt so wichtig dass herr der schon
zu ende geführt werden will das würde
das verhalten von einer sehr sehr stark
verändert
mit rabiaten schutz hinter mit lahm und
wittenberg politisches nicht einfach
bedeutet dass man mit der haltestelle
die schafe sind da nicht auf ein
hübsches hinter verteilt
mario wird es einfach schwierig warnte
dass man das halt machen und handschutz
aber tages ist nicht machbar aus meiner
sicht natürlich auch nicht der frage
natur und auch gleich oder mit ihnen
scharf aber es kommt mir so vor dass
gewässerschutz mit sicherheit möglich
ist das ist völlig 100 prozent
das verstehe ich den zukünftigen dienen
aber das ist ja meine helden schutz und
datenschützern hatte die stadt aber
einfach kein klotz nutzt das nutzte auf
sauberes wurden unternehmen stark sei
der schutz der wird nicht zu 100 prozent
über die zeit haben wir die quali
leistung parlament nutzte er die zucht
gehindert dort erwartet
da sind wir sehr glücklich über dieses
problem oder kompromiss verlang
verbreiten sie das ist kaum mehr werden
hundertprozentigen schutz weiter werde
man den früchten auf 0% kino bringen das
qualität und vor die autos dass toleranz
verhalten von mensch oder dass man
bereits in großer zahl für den chef oder
mehr oder weniger für ihre heute kino.to
wo der großteil der menschen die der
schweiz für befürworter natürlich ist
das nicht ihr vodafone umstand wenn
jedes hand es ist einfach das thema
großer akteur aber hauptsache das thema
mit dem wir das problem und das
funktioniert noch für den europacup
passiert ist zugegebenermaßen nicht
überall wo man sich die herr schmidt -
dir wird problematisch
der wolf kommt ins historische museum
uri es ist das tier welches im jahr
zuvor auf anordnung der regierung am
suchen pass erlegt worden ist
im 68 wurde das tier italienischer
herkunft genannt über 70 schafe und
ziegen hat der wolf auf den urner alpen
gerissen und jetzt mit einem auch das
ist eigentlich relativ kork sie da
schaut er geschäft groß wie oben
schneller war ganz klar dass der wolf
von jägern und schafhaltern verwünscht
doch förster im bündnerland begrüßen
seinem beitrag zum gleichgewicht der
natur im kalender gebiet wo sich das
erste wolfsrudel der schweiz gebildet
hat nahmen dank der wölfe die übergroßen
hirsch bestände ab und damit ebenso die
waldschäden
der wurf
er ist auch der grund weshalb renault
somerhalder in den amerikanischen
yellowstone park reist er will dort
erfahren was die rückkehr des wolfes im
ältesten nationalpark der welt bewirkt
hat prägend sind in dieser landschaft
die bisons zuweilen auch als
verkehrshindernis
[Musik]
und seit jeher ist das ebenso die heimat
der grizzlybär
[Musik]
doch der wolf war in diesem park
ausgerottet bis er 1995 wieder
angesiedelt worden ist mit fast
unglaublichen folgen die wölfe
veränderten das gesamte ökosystem ja
sogar den lauf der flüsse vor der
rückkehr der wölfe hatten die hirsche
und elche wenige feinde
sie vermehrten sich ungebremst fraßen
die wälder carl zerstörten den jungwuchs
doch mit den wölfen reduzierte sich die
hirsch und elf population drastisch die
vegetation erholte sich
vögel kehrten zurück und den bibern die
wieder bäume zum abladen fanden folgten
ihre väter die bisamratten
[Musik]
die wieder erstarkten wälder
stabilisierten die flussufer flüsse
begradigten ihren lauf eine
kettenreaktion hatte das ganze pflanzen
und tierreich erfasst die artenvielfalt
nahm zu ein gleichgewicht des ökosystems
stellte sich ein
dies innerhalb von nur 20 seither müssen
auch die bisons das wolfsrudel im auge
behalten
ansonsten haben sie den verlust ihrer
jungtiere zu fürchten
[Musik]
das bündnerland am ofenpass der
bartgeier ist mit einer spannweite von
drei metern der größte vogel europas
1913 wurde der letzte seiner art in den
europäischen alpen getötet nun fliegt er
wieder 1991 erhob sich erstmals ein
bartgeier wieder in den schweizer himmel
hier an ofenpass
[Musik]
der tierpark goldau ist für familien ein
beliebter freizeitpark wo auch ganz nahe
begegnungen mit tieren möglich sind doch
da ist eine ebenso wichtige
wissenschaftliche aufgabe golder wirkt
mit ausgerotteten tierarten zu einem
neuen leben in freiheit zu verhelfen
bei der wiederansiedlung der bartgeier
hatte biologe daniel hegglin allerdings
gegen alte märchen anzukämpfen
der große vogel ja glamour ja sogar
kleine kinder das mit dem kind das ist
glaube zur kasse aber das ist eher leer
gestanden und das sind schöne spannende
geschichte glücklich gemacht eindruck
andere zwecke kinder nie selber stelle
passiert konnte der geiger geholt und
wie sieht es mit den jagd gelösten des
großen geigers aus das war einfach
inzwischen noch über 30 jährige
geschichte sehr gut
naja also jetzt eine handvoll verbiete
schlag um region dokumentieren die
geschichte
es ist nur beobachtet worden dass sie in
jagdstrategie hat die zum thema das die
abstürze seltene bilder die zeigen wie
ein bartgeier aus stücke auf eine
geröllhalde fallen lässt um die knochen
zu zerkleinern
der bartgeier ernährt sich
ausschließlich von toten tieren seine
nahrung besteht zu 70 prozent aus
knochen
auf der obwaldner melchsee frutt ein
regnerischer sommertag
trotz der kälte sind mehrere hundert
menschen heraufgekommen sie wollen dabei
sein wenn in kürze zwei junge bartgeier
ausgewildert werden
szenario 4 prozent die partei ihre
modelle vorstellen
gegen 160 prüfungstage jetzt schon fünf
kilo schwer und hätte spannend wie die
nexans tor
das ist deutlich mehr als die schon fast
ersparen wie die von zwei meter fünfzig
für portugal jetzt das natürlich streng
diese strenger tag versehen wir müssen
aber sie erhole sich schneller und das
hälfte auf sie wartet und das konnte ein
schlosser männer aus gurt dass sie
gemeint eigentlich nur mit der positiven
sondern mittel bis negativen verbindet
sind wirklich extrem friedlich für die
diskussion die auswahl hier die sind
überhaupt nicht aggressiven stärken
[Musik]
der ruhige menschen zug durch die
neblige berglandschaft gleicht einer
prozession
[Musik]
zumindest ist es eine große sympathie
bekundung für einen vogel der immer noch
ein sehr seltenes bedrohtes tier ist
sympathien für ein eindrückliches
lebewesen dass keine anderen tiere jagt
das keinen anlass bietet für konflikte
auch nicht mit jägern
[Musik]
in unserer klinik wissen glaubt im fels
zu und das ist das weltereignis hinauf
zum horst darf nur noch eine kleine
gruppe steigen
die jungen bartgeier können noch nicht
fliegen können sich das futter noch
nicht selbst beschaffen
sie werden in den nächsten wochen
weiterhin betreuung nötig haben
[Musik]
zurück in waltrop camp im deutschen
überlingen etwas oval vom bodensee
wollte ist flugtraining angesagt sie
nutzer an schmalstieg ist vor allem
daran gelegen die vögel vor dem
übungsflug zu beruhigen
als fluggerät dient ein motorisierter
gleitschirm der gut 40 stundenkilometer
schnell fliegt eine geschwindigkeit die
gegner der waldrappe entspricht
[Applaus]
wenn die hannes gefühl hat man sollte
die ziehmutter hat die vögel aus dem
gehege gelassen
der flug soll rund eine halbe stunde
dauern bis zur zwischenlandung auf einem
kleinen flugplatz
[Musik]
projektleiter johannes fritz begleitet
den wald ab schwarm am boden
fantastisch
haben sie angst seine formation gezeigt
was muss in dieser jahreszeit eher
ungewöhnlich
fantastisch
etwas dahinter steckt dass man einmal so
weit kommt dass die vögel in dieser art
und weise der fluggerät vorlegen
haupt einspruch ich am anfang für die
vögel und das braucht wochen bis sie das
fluggerät mit der bezugspersonen
verbindung bringen
erst diese verbindung zwischen
fluggeräte bezugsperson eintippen einer
grund den fluggeräten aufzufliegen also
fantastische arbeiten begeistern
nachdem in der woche zuvor das
flugtraining wegen schlechten wetters
ausgesetzt werden musste ist die
erleichterung nun groß dass alles
geklappt hat dass alle vögel mitgeflogen
sind die wiederansiedlung des weltcups
in europa ist ein aufwendiges teures
projekt getragen auch durch die eu
ich verstehe sie auch das leben als
auftrag wenn sich die möglichkeit ergibt
eine derart wieder in ihrem angestammten
lebensraum heimisch zu machen und diese
die haut durch menschliche einwirkung
verschwunden ist dann haben wir doch
auch als gesellschaft die verantwortung
dass zumindest zu versuchen
johannes fritz hat sein fluggerät
mitgebracht wer wird als zweiter pilot
mit den vögeln zum camp zurück fliegen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
seit vier jahren werden waldrappe
ausschuss auf diesem wege wieder
zuzufügen
zusammen mit den wild boten der
ausgewilderten tiere werden dieses jahr
wieder rund 100 war trappe in europa
leben 400 jahre nach ihrer ausrottung
bald wird dieses camp abgebrochen
denn der tag des aufbruchs rückt näher
in zwei wochen soll der große flug die
sogenannte migration in die toskana
starten
hoffentlich sicher alles geklappt das
will die ganze etappen mit ihnen
schaffen und das werden sicher im winter
gebiet ankommen damit sie dann ein
freies leben führen können an einem
augusttag ist es soweit in überlingen
beginnt der flug in den süden
24 tage werther dauern eine
herausforderung ist die überquerung der
alpen
[Musik]
die berge sind geschafft start zum flug
über die poebene richtung vor enz
30 vertraute sind noch dabei ein vogel
staub auf der reise nach dem eher
metallteile gefressen hatte
nach 9 140 kilometern erreichen die
waldrappe ihr winterquartier in
orbetello
[Musik]
die schweiz ist auch ein land der
leuchtend grünen wiesen
doch was die artenvielfalt anbelangt
sind das oft grüne wüste
die intensive nutzung der einsatz von
pestiziden dies zerstört den lebensraum
zahlreicher lebewesen 45.000 tier und
pflanzenarten existieren in der schweiz
tausende davon sind vom aussterben
bedroht
doch das grün des mittellandes wird auch
selbst bedrängt jährlich werden 3400
hektar kulturland zu straßen und
bauplätzen
das entspricht der fläche von rund 5.000
fußballfeldern wohlstand und wachstum
verlangen raum auch in den alpen
besonders im tessin ist in den letzten
jahrzehnten kulturland verschwunden doch
nicht menschliche aktivität hat die
wiesn verschwinden lassen sondern das
gegenteil davon
der rückzug des menschen aus den steilen
abgelegenen hängen die wildnis kehrt
zurück in die tessiner täler der wald
wächst eine waldschule oberhalb von luca
toni hat sie mitgegründet
der tessiner ist forstingenieur und
urwald fachmann ein wildnis pionier im
tessin hat profi mitgeholfen mehrere
waldreservate zu schaffen
er kennt die kritik dass mit dem starken
wald wachstum die biodiversität also die
artenvielfalt leider
ziel ist die freie natur entfaltet unter
vertraue idealfall dinge und die freude
war es passiert
schönheit spielespezialist nicht so dass
ich wunderbar die dunklen stellen die
schlechte dass ich genau für mich
spielen und da wenig später liegen stets
an ist derzeit nur dass cottbus lehrt
hat wissenschaftler so oft leider so der
kaiser kreis modell oder ddr für natur
im wald reservat verzichtet der mensch
auf die holznutzung einer tour wald auf
dem weg zum urwald totholz bleibt liegen
doch tod bleibt es nicht und dass das
wichtig ist schon der boden für derrick
von waldholz lebendig vielen menschen
macht er jedoch angst dieser wald ohne
menschliche aufsicht angst forderten ist
ja unbehagen nicht
das kann man verstehen zum teil
wenn das ist angst vor der reformation
aalen vom unbekannten um nicht
kontrolliert und so bissig aber wer weiß
was alles so negativ dann passiert aber
ich bin ja ich bin ich bin mächtig wir
haben alles unter kontrolle
unaufhaltsam wächst der wald im tessin
nicht weil die menschen es so möchten
sondern weil sie es nicht verhindern
können
auch in unserer lonetal liegen die
dörfer heute inmitten des waldes viele
siedlungen sind aufgegeben worden und
auch der holzschlag rechnet sich längst
nicht mehr so hat man die realität
akzeptiert und aus dem nordhang ein wald
reservat gemacht eines der grössten der
schweiz
die bevölkerung hat zugestimmt
auch weil die jagd und das pilzsammeln
weiterhin erlaubt sind
nun lässt sich allmählich ahnen wie ein
urwald aussehen könnte als förster hat
roberto buzzi damals für diese wildnis
gekämpft
die reaktionen monster nonntal sind
meistens gut sie war für mich
überraschend ich an oskar dass das
nachholt
doch als olympia oder viele boxen
naja da machen wir es kurz an denn hansi
schönheit vom gesetzlich es nochmal nach
dagegen unterlagen exkursion von helen
mirren älterer herr als möglich sondern
liebeskomödie und der markt jetzt nach
der wahl mit anderen khalid das ist dass
ich den entscheidenden momenten
entscheiden
[Applaus]
es ist für mich wirklich zählen basel
sauter verdient seinen lebensunterhalt
als imker vor 40 jahren ist er als
aussteiger hierher
zuhinterst ins unser nuhnetal gezogen
und ist mit seiner familie geblieben
in diesen jahrzehnten hat er erfahren
wie die menschen gegangen sind und die
wildnis gekommen ist nun lebt der mitten
in halt ich bin begeistert
mark stand und im gegenteil es freut
mich irre in ruhe in rio haase
vorstellen könne zwar irgendwann hat
sich ja wieder andere wenn es unter in
der fläche der masse satt und künftig
das bedürfnis equipment italo go zone
und deine werte weiteres stück wald
abgeholt damit man wieder platt sondern
bis pflanzen zum heute war weiß aber
dass man immer gut vorstellen
5 uhr morgens zu unterst in einem
talkessel der obwaldner melchsee frutt
noch hat der angekündigte hitzetag die
2000 meter über meer nicht erreicht die
biologin franziska lörcher steigt auf
zum felsband wo sich der horst der zwei
jungen bartgeier befindet so früh am
morgen darauf will man eigentlich gar
nicht und eigentlich innerhalb von einer
minute praktisch und zigarren zu groß
mitbekommen dass mir das wort bringen
zwei wochen zuvor sind die beiden war
ein männchen und ein weibchen in einer
felsnische ausgewildert worden
und weil sie noch nicht flügge sind
benötigen sie vorerst noch futter von
menschenhand das weibchen bfg 960 hat
sich einen sehr exponierten schlafplatz
über dem abgrund ausgesucht vorsichtiger
ist das männchen welches sich unsichtbar
in der höhle aufhält
dass sich das weibchen meist über der
felswand aufhält wird ihm später zum
verhängnis werden
auch nach franziska lengers abgang
bleibt ein auge auf die vögel gerichtet
ein kameraauge
und gesteht ich habe auch super aber wir
haben konkrete gehindert und wegen 106
wohnen und zogen und schlafplatz und
frisches futter an der flanke gegenüber
vom horst sind zwei container in die
bergwelt gesetzt wurde
während dreier monate werden von hier
aus die jungvögel beobachtet bishara
insgesamt sieben balkons bildet das mit
einem 2 0 ins tor
der nächste findet gutmann herford eps
darum regelmäßig über träume und ist zum
beispiel cloud live bilder vom horst
besonders beobachtet werden die ersten
flugübungen sind die jungen bartgeier
ist man flugfähig werden sie ein weites
streifgebiet erkunden dieses kann bis
ans mittelmeer oder an die nordsee
reichen
doch je jünger die vögel war der
ausbildung sind desto eher werden sie
später zum brüten zurückkehren zu können
im alpinen frühsommer ist das entrückte
bergtal eine menschen arme
überwältigende blut wiese
doch schon bald wird auch hier oben
näher betriebsamkeit herrschen dann
ziehen die älbler mit ihrem vieh in die
nähe der großen vögel einige tage später
wird sich im post der bartgeier eine
tragödie ereignet
das weibchen bfg 960 das stets am
abgrund balancierte wird von einer
sturmböe erfasst und beim sturz über die
felswand getötet werden
und was ist aus dem urner bären geworden
dem ersten der seit fast 200 jahren in
die schweiz zurückgekehrt ist
am susten horn auf der berner seite der
kantonsgrenze kam es ende juni zu einer
denkwürdigen begegnung roland sein war
mit seinem bruder unterwegs zum gipfel
als er im schnee deren spuren entdeckt
juni der größe egal dass das war schnell
klar es ist mulmig wurde
die spur ist sehr frisch und vor der
größe haben muss dass muss ja nicht
alles riskiert und sich bei der sehr
unsicher wurden was ist die zunge spüren
eben nicht zu verbessern
die spur zog sich richtung gipfel hinauf
auf 3500 meter über meer
eine pause gemacht und brücken und
landschaftliche knies und ex ein zweiter
plateau und wahre endlich eine sehr
schnelle tempo über über die hoffnung
flächige gesprungen ist richtig führe
also richtige stelle
messerli nervös obwohl das wasser länger
zu verzweifelten situation ist das motto
frische überrascht sie ist eine große
freude
ein rätselhaft ist hier dieser namenlose
uhr na wer wochenlang bleibt der
unsichtbar
dann taucht er unvermittelt wieder auf
weit ab von allen futterquellen in einer
grandiosen doch eigentlich
lebensfeindlichen welt aus fels und eis
im osten russlands liegt kamtschatka
halbinsel im nördlichen pazifik
größer als deutschland doch kaum
besiedelt es ist ein rauchendes land von
den 160 vulkanen kamtschatka sie 29
aktiv reno sommerhalder suche nach der
intakten natur endet hier in dieser
weitgehend unberührten wildnis
seit jahren kommt er immer wieder
hierher denn kamtschatka ist nicht nur
land der vulkane sondern auch ein reich
der bären in diesen tagen warten sie an
den gewässern auf die ankunft der
pazifischen wildlachs
und dann kommen sie in riesigen
schwärmen
lachse am ziel einer langen wanderung
aus dem pazifik zurück zu ihrem
herkunftsort um zu laichen
und dann meist zu verändern
der tod der einen ist das überlebende
andere öko system nennt sich das noch
ist das futterangebot verschwenderisch
groß doch auch dieser wildnis ist
beträgt in asien steigt die nachfrage
rapide nach russischem wildlachs
nachrodt zum gold dem lachskaviar
es droht eine überfischung und so bleibt
auch dieses menschen lewe naturparadies
nicht verschont vor menschlichen tun
[Musik]
präsentiert wurde für 100